un champ pour salles de classe à 80 km
de dijon ces jeunes de seconde après
l'élevage canin et félin cette maison
familiale rurale de semur en auxois
c'est un choix personnel ce qui me plaît
après en milieu rural c'est vrai qu'on
va être plus centrés sur nous que étant
donné le nombre l'effectif qu'on a on
est plus centré sur nous on va plus nous
aider après voilà on a les grands
terrains donc c'est plus pratique la
campagne
voilà c'est bien pour être avec les
chiens moment familial un peu comme dit
le nom m'amuse rafle familiale rurale et
puis on sent un peu tous bien
joli et tu récompense c'est très très
bien c'est passionné d'animaux se
retrouvent chaque soir en études de 112
jeunes ils vivent
la quasi totalité des élèves 19 heures
fin des cours ici pas de distribution de
copies mais deux portables
les élèves n'ont accès à leur téléphone
qu'une demi heure par jour dans
s'habituer on se parle plus c'est vrai
qu'on se parle plus quand on n'a pas
noté ford entre camarades on va dire que
quand on est dessus on y du
c'est comme ça on est enfermé dans une
bulle et comme dans toute vie en
collectivité il faut aussi faire la
vaisselle
simplement de la m et 8e qui te saoule
ou pas wizzgo amant oui c'est bon après
faut le fermer
mais voilà c'est pas parce qu'on aime le
pouce fois une vie d'internât avec un
seul jour de sortie le mardi chez avec
mes amis on voit à l'intermarché balader
dans la ville
vous faites quoi intermarché on achète à
est ce que vous avez envie de sortir si
beaucoup même c'est pas vous dernière
marque de tendresse avant l'extinction
des feux même loin de chez eux ces
adolescents ont encore besoin d'être
dorloter une vie au vert à leur rythme
un passage en douceur vers l'âge adulte
qui les fuit à demain
[Musique]